(crowd applause)
- One of my first things
ever to do after Idol
and I don't know if it's
one of your first things
you've probably been dancing
since you were a kid.
But... we met and you were back up dancing
and I was doing Miss Independent.
- Yes, you had just won American Idol.
- We were in a Walmart parking lot.
This is not a joke.
I sang till like 2 am and
like we were just out there
and she was dancing and I was like
"God you're beautiful, can I
dance like that maybe one day?"
No, um and then turns out I
just sing well. Sometimes.
And anyway but it was the
most random thing because
I was so excited because I had no friends.
You don't even know this
part I'm about to tell you.
But I had no friends because at home I did
but I was working in LA
I didn't know anyone,
and so it was just nice
to like see a Texas girl
and just so nice and you were kind.
- Oh that's so sweet.
- And I really needed somebody
to be kind in that moment
and you were and so thank you so much.
- Ohhhhh, Kelly, that's so sweet!
- No it was really nice I was so sad cause
I didn't have any friends like out in LA
all my friends were in
Texas and so I was like
I miss Texas people.
- I so remember this
and for like the entire
time this was a longer than we...
It was a long time ago.
- It was like five years ago.
- You know, we were like
20, which is 2 years ago.
- Yeah.
- Um I told everyone that
would listen to me I was like
"Kelly is the nicest, most amazing person,
she's gonna be huge!"
And you know listen, I'm
psychic ya know, look at this.
- Yeah what else do you project?
- Yeah right so but-
That was funny.
Do you remember we were dancing
on a stage that they built
in the parking lot?
- Literally in the parking lot!
Uh huh.
- And we ran back to the break room.
- Oh break room!
- Yes!
- People were having their
smoke breaks and I was like
stripping clothes.
- And you're trying to
keep it cool and be like
so professional, yeah.
- Yes.
And we're like "hey!"
And then we're running
through the aisles to get
back on the stage.
- Yes!
- There was so many times-
- It was ghetto it was awesome I liked it!
(crowd laughs)
- I was back in Texas, we were-
I was so happy to have gotten the job.
It was just like, it was a fun experience.
But that picture I
found I couldn't believe
I found this picture.
- I saw!
I know I saw!
- Our style, everything.
It was everything
It was so great.
- Well I was in jeans I was
quite very comfortable actually.
- Yeah.
- Ah, I'm just remembering that.